Science has long studied how animals talk
to one another.
They may not have language like you and I
but almost every animal on the planet has
some form of communication system, sometimes
these can be simple, like the bark of a dog
or extremely complex like the sonar waves
of a Dolphin.
Seriously dolphins are better communicators
than most humans, scientists have found that
dolphins can actually send a complete image
via sonar, so if Terry the dolphin likes the
look of a certain fish he can actually send
an accurate photo of that fish to his mate
Steve the dolphin, so Steve can come and help
Terry to catch it.
This is the biological equivalent of humans
sending each other holograms, which we can’t
even do yet.
So basically dolphins are the omnipotent master
race and we have unknowingly been living on
their planet for millions of years.
But that’s enough about our evil dolphin
overlords, what about other fishy communication
systems?
How about the humble herring?
Well herring are quite simply the undisputed
Nobel Prize winners of underwater communication,
as they use farts to talk to each other.
Speaking of Nobel Prizes, the fellow who discovered
this, Dr Bob Batty at the Scottish Association
for Marine Science, won the Ig Nobel Prize,
an award for research that first makes people
laugh and then makes people think, for his
fish fart research.
Dr Batty and two of his colleagues in Canada
became enthralled by herring farts when they
noticed that small gas bubbles are rapidly
released from the rear of herrings every night.
So obviously they immediately dropped all
their actual research and setup round-the-clock
infrared video cameras and underwater microphones
to monitor herrings.
They noticed that every night, when the sun
goes down the herring start to break wind
and they picked up very high-pitched raspberry-like
noises on the microphones.
It has long been common knowledge that herring
swim to the surface to take in huge amounts
of air then store it in their bladder and
then when they see a predator they release
one huge bubble of air from their bottom to
attempt to scare off the predator.
But through Bob Batty and his Canadian colleagues’
research, we now know that they do a very
similar thing to talk to the rest of their
shoal.
What the team noticed was that the more herring
that are in the tank, the more often they
fart, indicating that it must be some form
of communication.
The main way the herrings use their behind
to communicate is to maintain order within
the shoal.
When herring school they do so in a perfect
grid pattern with immaculately measured spacing
in-between one-another.
The gap left between each fish is the typical
distance that a prey will jump away from the
herring when it attempts to eat it.
Therefore, this grid formation allows for
optimal schooling.
So that’s all very well but how does a school
of thousands of herring perfectly organize
themselves into an immaculate grid formation?
By farting in each other’s faces.
By releasing noxious gas from their bottom
into the face of the fish behind them, they
can precisely control the distance between
each other and maintain their perfectly-spaced
grid.
It’s kind of like constantly farting on
the train so nobody sits next to you.
But these aren’t your average farts, herring
rapidly release around 60 short bursts of
gas from their anal duct, over approximately
6 seconds.
The resulting sound is a single, continuous
burst of high-frequency noise.
Scientists have named these FRTs, I’m not
kidding.
Which stands for, Fast Repetitive Tick sounds.
The benefit of this noise is that most other
fish can’t hear this high-pitched buzzing
sound, but herring can.
So by only farting to communicate they are
able to travel in huge schools and remain
relatively undetected by predators.
In 1994 Sweden almost went to war with Russia
over herring farts.
The Swedish military detected an almost metallic
clicking sound underwater, incredibly similar
to the noise produced by Russian submarines.
Sweden went on high alert and dispatched military
units to search for intruders within their
waters.
Sweden even wrote a letter to Russia demanding
them to withdraw their submarines from their
waters at once.
But they quickly swept the whole thing under
the rug when a Swedish scientist discovered
that the sound they recorded was not enemy
submarines but a school of thousands of farting
herrings.
Nature is weird and sometimes it seems like
evolution has totally lost it.
It’s not just herring though, human’s
do some pretty strange stuff too, but no matter
how weird you think you are, just remember,
at least you don’t talk out of your arse,
unless your name is Donald Trump.